foreign ministers of g7 countries
including canada forming a united front
against russia the focus of talks at a
gathering in liverpool england have
largely focused on the ramped up
military presence of russian troops on
its border with ukraine we've been clear
that any incursion by russia into
ukraine would have massive consequences
for which there would be a severe cost
saturday u.s president joe biden who
spoke with russia's vladimir putin
earlier this week was even more direct
i've made it absolutely clear president
putin that
if he moves on ukraine
the economic consequences for his
economy are going to be devastating
devastating
a ramping up of rhetoric is being felt
across europe with the vatican calling
for calm
pope francis prayed for ukraine asking
that tensions be resolved through
serious international dialogue and not
with weapons moscow's latest buildup of
troops and military equipment is along
the border of eastern ukraine near an
area largely controlled by
russian-backed separatists the
cross-border tensions are a reminder of
what happened in 2014 when putin annexed
crimea
at that time western nations imposed
crippling sanctions on russia and
they're threatening to do the same again
but observers say one big difference is
western nations weren't taken by
surprise this time so we shouldn't
expect a matching of military might the
message here is we will not fight you
but we will
raise the cost of any further aggression
but statement points out putin is
unpredictable and at this point his end
goal is unclear
he's not a chess master
he's a judo artist and that means that
he just looks for individual
opportunities to strike not really
thinking five steps ahead and what
nato's and the g7 are doing is trying to
signal that this one step is too costly
on its own so now the world waits to see
if putin heeds that warning
mike lacouter global news ottawa